bonjour natacha polony merci de répondre
à nos questions sur arte france
comment est ce que vous avez accueilli
cette quatrième allocutions
présidentielles liées à la crise du
corona virus la réouverture des crèches
et des écoles pour laurence mais ce sera
certainement bien accueillie par les
parents parce que ça ne va pas risqué de
prêter à des discussions d'ordre
sanitaire vie d'abord de toute façon
tout est complexe et il faut s'attendre
à ce qu'il y ait des débats des
discussions jusqu'au 11 mai première
chose que l'on peut dire c'est que
emmanuel macron a été concret à apporter
des réponses sur l'organisation
ce qui permet aux français de savoir à
quoi s'attendre après il n'a pas répondu
aux questions essentielles qui
permettent de discuter de ce qui va se
passer parce que la question c'est pas
seulement celle de savoir si nous allons
sortir avec quand nous allons sortir
c'est la question des tests et des
masques qui permettent d'être en
sécurité
alors il explique à un moment de son
allocution que le port du masque pourra
être systématique dans les transports ça
c'est pas clair je suis à aucun moment
il ne revient sur ce mensonge qui était
que les masques ne servait à rien et il
faut là il va falloir pendant le mois
qui vient être un petit peu plus clair
sur la nécessité que tout le monde porte
des masques sur les tests c'est la même
chose
les français ont besoin de savoir de
combien de test on dispose
comment ils seront mis en oeuvre or là
pour l'instant
le président continuent à dire on ne va
pas testé tout le monde ça ne servirait
à rien mais si ça sert à rien pourquoi
l'allemagne le fait l'allemagne qui s'en
sort beaucoup mieux que nous donc là
aussi
ne recommençons pas cette erreur qui
consiste à habiller la pénurie
c'est par un discours qui serait un
discours faut donc je pense qu'il va
falloir encore allez un petit peu plus
loin là il a reconnu des failles des
ratés il va falloir aller un petit peu
plus loin dans la vérité des choses tout
simplement pour que chacun puisse se
dire que quand il reviendra à sa vie à
peu près normale qui ne sera pas la vie
normale d'avant bien au moins le minimum
de sécurité sera respectée mais ça va
aussi évidemment dépendre de chacun et
en effet sur la question des masques par
exemple c'est aussi une responsabilité
individuelle il va falloir prendre des
habitudes
vous avez parlé que de failles de rater
ce qu'il faut y voir un mea culpa est un
changement de ton dans la communication
du président lui qui disait qu'il ne
devait pas y avoir de polémique en temps
de guerre puisqu'il a souvent utilisé ce
mot guerre alors lui a parlé de failles
de rater après à vrai dire fou de savoir
si c'est un changement de communication
le problème n'est pas que ce soit un
changement de communication le problème
est de savoir si politiquement les bons
choix sont faits reconnaître des failles
et des ratés il y était obligé puisque
de fait tous les français s'en sont
rendu compte
ils se sont même rendus compte qu'il y
avait manche on mange sur la question
des masques c'est pas seulement des
failles et des rapts et c'est des
mensonges pour habitude pour habiller
des failles et des ratés qui ne relèvent
pas seulement des manuels macron mais
qui relève du gouvernement précédent de
celui de françois hollande et de jean
marc ayrault
alors simplement les français auraient
sans doute préféré qu'on leur parle
comme à des adultes et il va falloir
aller encore plus loin dans cette façon
de parler aux citoyens comme à des
adultes et de leur faire confiance sur
leur capacité à s'adapter et à juger sur
la question des tests j insiste il faut
être beaucoup plus clair dire à quel
moment une envisage d'avoir suffisamment
de tests pour pouvoir tester l'ensemble
de la population dans une maladie où la
plupart des gens n'ont pas de symptômes
et donc si on attend qu'ils aient des
symptômes pour les tester ils ont eu le
temps de répandre le virus à peu près
partout donc pour ce qui est de la
sécurité en fait la sécurité dépend
aussi de la fiabilité du discours
politique
on vous venez d'évoquer évidemment la
pénurie de masques les
les polémiques liées aux tests et quiz
j'ai envie de dire de la dimension
économique également rebâtir notre
économie garder notre indépendance
financière agricole industriel
sanitaires ça veut dire quoi exactement
est ce que c'est une souveraineté
économique c'est une façon de mettre la
pression sur bruxelles alors que les
vingt-sept peinent à s'entendre sur la
réponse commune à apporter à cette crise
sanitaire
en effet une dimension économique
absolument majeur dans le sens où on a
tous compris que cette crise serait
terrifiante là pour la restauration
l'hôtellerie
'l'annonce d'hier est une catastrophe
absolue pour des petits restaurateurs de
savoir qu'ils vont devoir attendre au
moins mi juillet avant de rouvrir c'est
absolument terrifiant c'est à dire qu'il
y en a qui vont rester sur le carreau et
comme d'habitude ce sont les petits qui
vont rester sur le carreau alors là
aussi on se doute que le gouvernement
essaye de résoudre le problème
essaye de trouver des solutions l'appel
des manuels macro moi ce que les banques
jouent leur rôle c'est très gentil mais
on sait très bien dans cette ère est que
les banques justement ne joue pas ou pas
suffisamment
donc il va falloir encadrer tout ça je
pense que ce n'est que le début de la
crise économique à venir
or ce qui est à craindre c'est que
l'union européenne par exemple se
déchirent à nouveau et en particulier
que les pays du nord comme les pays bas
refusent de prendre les mesures
nécessaires on se souvient qu'après la
crise de 2008
c'est la demande d'orthodoxie budgétaire
trop rapide qui a grippé la reprise
là ça risque d'être la même chose et de
même que on peut se demander comment va
être pensé la suite en matière de
justement de souveraineté c'est très
amusant de voir emmanuel macron parler
de souveraineté alimentaire de sourire
on est ravis qu'ils découvrent enfin que
c'est absolument nécessaire c'était pas
exactement son logiciel jusqu'à présent
en gros il nous expliquait que tous ceux
qui parlaient de souveraineté était de
d'affreux ringard et qu'il fallait être
ouvert sur le monde on s'aperçoit que
l'ouverture si ça signifie la dépendance
c'est une catastrophe
donc il a changé de logiciel tant mieux
on est ravi et si réellement les actes
suivent les mots on applaudira mais pour
l'instant on attend de voir les actes en
la matière parce que c'est un
bouleversement total
il va falloir réindustrialiser le pays
il va falloir faire en sorte que les
l'agriculture française puisse
réellement développer ses produits
actuellement la grande distribution
achète en partie français pas seulement
et c'est une nouveauté comment ce qu'est
ce qu'il en sera dans quelques mois
c'est tout cela qui va falloir voir ça
va être très long mais est-ce que
emmanuel macron semis en chantre du
souverainisme industriels alors que le
chef de l'état a fait choix de se
désengager du capital d'entreprises
stratégiques comme alstom par exemple
mais heureux les convertis tant mieux on
va pas on ne va pas lui en vouloir
d'avoir compris que son modèle était
absolument catastrophique dans un dans
un moment de crise comme celui ci encore
une fois il y a les mots et sur les mots
on est ravi que beaucoup de gens il
n'est pas emmanuel macron n'est pas le
seul depuis ces derniers jours le nombre
de personnes qui s'aperçoivent que
c'était que c'est absolument
catastrophique de ne pas fabriquer les
médicaments en france c'est quelque
chose d'extraordinaire mais pendant des
années quand on expliqué qu'il y avait
des filières stratégiques on se ferait
et je faisais rire au nez
donc aujourd'hui nous avons tous compris
que l'indépendance moque emmanuel macron
a repris hier soir comme il a repris le
boat souveraineté l'indépendance c'est
essentiel parce que c'est une protection
des citoyens
simplement une fois qu'on a dit ça il
faut mettre en oeuvre
c'est ça nécessite de faire des choix ça
nécessite d'être extrêmement rigoureux
et ça nécessite de fâcher quelques
intérêts divers donc on verra bien au
pied du mur où en sera le masson merci
beaucoup à natacha polony d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes la directrice de la rédaction
de l'hebdomadaire marianne